Welcome to the class where you get serious about web development.
By the end of this course, your code will be professional, and
professional code is what will get you your next job.
You'll be able to build an organized application, both with or
without an organizational JavaScript library or framework.
You'll also be able to look at those libraries and figure out how to use them.
And you'll understand why using libraries can be a good idea.
So, what's the progression of this course?
First, we'll build an application together the way we already know how.
Then we'll look at some of the problems with what we know, and
learn some techniques to solve those problems.
Next, we'll move on to learning frameworks.
And finally, we'll learn to pick up some code we've never seen before and
how to tackle that otherwise scary process.
The final project will be a neighborhood map.
It'll be completely self-led and good enough to put in your portfolio for
job interviews.
Now, I want you to take your time with this course and projects.
Don't rush.
Together we'll be fundamentally changing the way you think about application
development, so give yourself the space and time to learn it properly.
And take some time also to embark on projects of your own outside of the class.
Find some time to play.
Now, this course will be challenging at points.
So, if you're having a rough time at any point, it's not you.
This is by design.
You might feel scared, like I did when I first learned this, and
it's normal to feel that way when you learn anything new.
But you will get there.
And your successes, well, your successes will be thrilling.
Bask in them.